uh i wanted to situate this uh initially
on where we are with delta because
what's happening is omicron is coming on
the back of a still high rate of delta
transmission and hospitalization
so in the first slide what we have is
the number of people testing positive
for covid in the uk
and that has been drifting upwards not
at a very rapid rate but it has been
drifting upwards
the omicron data aren't really going to
be visible in this
for a few days but they will become
visible over time
next slide please
the number of people in the hospital
with covid in the uk has uh because of
the booster vaccination program in
particular uh been drifting down uh
until this point in time with the
numbers going into hospital uh reducing
although that's now stabilized slightly
and that's really because the boosters
are particularly going to protect and
are protecting people who are in the
highest risk categories as the prime
minister has said
next slide please
and the number of people in the uk who
are dying uh has again gradually been
decreasing over time but uh is still an
a daily average
of 121 deaths from covid
so we still have a significant issue
with covid and i think anybody who
speaks to anyone working in the nhs
would say that is on top of an
incredibly busy system
next slide please
in terms of our main major counter
measures of course the biggest one as
the prime minister has said is boosting
and this is steadily increasing so we
now have over a third of those who are
eligible have already had a booster and
they are by and large the most
vulnerable uh third but there's still
people who are in uh in higher risk
groups have not been boosted
and of course we have to move down those
groups and that is going to become
absolutely critical we think
as we move on to into a period where
omicron becomes significant and probably
then becomes dominant
next slide please
and if this is a just a data data just
to
show
quite how effective with the variance
we've had to date vaccination
can be and what it compares is in the
dark lines the hospitalization rate
in the the blue black bars
in those who are
unvaccinated
and in the orange bars those who are
vaccinated with two doses this is
largely protecting against delta
but as you can see at every age
a really substantial improvement
in your protection
next slide please
so now we move on to the data on omicron
and these are data probably people have
seen versions of in uh in media over the
last few days but i think they do need
uh point needs sort of uh fleshing out a
bit
so these are the number of people
testing positive for covert 19 in south
africa at this point in time the big
increase in kovid in south africa is
virtually all
the omicron variant
and this is now spread all around south
africa and as you can see this is an
incredibly steep
increase
in rates and we're now seeing this
translating into increasing increases in
hospitalization so for example i was
talking to some of my colleagues from
south africa this afternoon and they
were saying that uh informal data still
to be uh still to be added to but there
was around about a 300
percent increase on hospitalizations uh
over the last week
so um some of those will have come in
with
omicron and some of them will come in as
a result of on the crown but the fact is
those numbers are going up very sharply
next slide please
so what's happening here in the uk well
i'm afraid that the data here are now
clear
what you can see here
is the number on the left
and on the right the percentage
of cases with a with what's called s
gene target failure this is a marker for
omicron virtually all the cases now
who've got this marker will have omicron
a very small number at the bottom will
not
and as you can see whether you look at
the absolute count or the percentage
this is going up incredibly fast now
and as the prime minister has said this
is doubling at this point in time it may
slow down and the aim of the measures
announced by the prime minister is to
slow things down but it's doubling
currently between two and three every
two and three
days that is an extraordinarily fast
rate and you therefore can get with very
small numbers to very large numbers
really quite quickly
now the question obviously people
reasonably want to ask is will this feed
through to people in hospital and how
quickly
and i think i'd just like to
just point out two realities
first of all i need the first one is a
good one but the moment the spread is in
younger people who would you would not
expect to go into hospital and is once
it starts moving up the ages and into
vulnerable groups that you'll start to
see that so there will be a lag as it
moves into more vulnerable groups
and then we know from previous ways and
this is not particularly surprising that
there is a delay between people becoming
infected with covid and ending up with
symptoms and then with hospitalization
so there's usually about a two week
delay we would therefore not expect
that these cases that the case rates in
hospital will start to go up for a
number of probably two to three weeks
and in that period if you're doubling up
at the speed we're talking about now we
move from very small numbers to really
substantial numbers and it will keep on
doubling
and that really is the reason
why these measures have been announced
by the prime minister as agreed by
ministers today